Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody, to The
David Pakman Show. Luke Beasley here filling
in for David while he is away. We have a wild
show ahead of us, so stick around. Let's dive
in. Ladies and gentlemen, I have for you the
true Twitter files. What should be the actual
conversation going on around Twitter, social media
platforms and their role in our political process,
specifically the 2020 election now. Before we
dive into these fascinating details. What am I
connecting this to? Well, of course, shortly
after Elon Musk became the head of Twitter,
he started promoting and facilitating the Twitter
files. And these were supposed to reveal through
the analysis of behind the scenes records at
Twitter, the way that Twitter went after Trump
treated him so poorly, treated the conservative
movement so poorly and unfairly, and made the
difference in the 2020 election. Well, as David
has done and I've done on our respective shows,
when you actually walk through the details
of the Twitter files that is not shown,
it's pretty dishonest narrative because when
you dive into it, you realize these claims
are not being backed up in the way that
they should. And this does not show what
people are saying that it shows. Right. And so
within that context, I want to dive in to now.
A much more profound and fascinating
part of this in my mind, which is
through the January six Select Committee's
investigation, a part of it that was previously
unseen up until now reveals that actually the
exact opposite was going on. Twitter and other
social media platforms were giving preferential
treatment to Trump to far right extremists out
of fear of backlash. And so the opposite was going
on. Then the narrative that we've heard from right
wingers as of late, this is truly interesting
stuff. They decided not to include it in their
final report because a number of reasons. My take
on it was you kind of can only get the public to
focus on a few things you can't give a million
things focus on with this type of story. And the
extensive nature of the report was already going
to be quite the batch of information to go through
to talk about and to open up a whole nother can of
worms with its whole nother group of controversies
and all of that. They did see as worth it. And
so it wasn't including the report, but they did
a lot of investigations, a lot of interviews in
regard to this exact issue. The Washington Post
has a story on it, what the January six probe
found out about social media but didn't report.
The January six committee spent months gathering
stunning new details on how social media companies
failed to address the online extremism and calls
for violence that preceded the Capitol riot. The
evidence they collected was written up in a 122
page, four page memo that was circulated among
the committee, according to a draft viewed by
The Washington Post. But in the end, committee
leaders declined to delve into those topics in
detail in their final report, reluctant to dig
into the roots of domestic extremism taking hold
in the Republican Party beyond former President
Donald Trump and concerned about the risks of
a public battle with powerful tech companies.
Congressional investigators found evidence
that tech platforms, especially Twitter,
failed to heed their own employees warnings
about violent rhetoric on their platforms
and bent their rules to avoid penalizing
conservatives, particularly then President Trump,
out of fear of reprisals. The draft report
details how most platforms did not take
dramatic steps to rein in extremist content
until after the attack on the Capitol. Despite
clear red flags across the Internet. So
bending their own rules to allow Trump
to continue violating their rules without being
held accountable now will skip over a part of this
just for the sake of time that walks through the
specifics of why they decided not to include it.
In their final report, but will pick up here
titled Did Twitter Give Trump a pass? Some of what
investigators uncovered in their interviews with
employees of the platforms contradicts Republican
claims that the tech companies displayed a liberal
bias in their moderation decisions. Contradicts
that. An allegation that has gained new attention
recently as Musk has promoted a series of leaked
internal communications known as the Twitter
files. The transcripts indicate the reverse,
with former Twitter employees describing how the
company gave Trump special treatment. Twitter
employees, they testified, could not even
view the former president's tweets and one
of their key content moderation tools. And they
ultimately had to create a Google document to
keep track of his tweets as calls grew to suspend
his account. Twitter was terrified of the backlash
they would get if they followed their own rules
and applied them to Donald Trump, said one former
employee. So this highlights a few things.
The takeaways, I think, should be number one.
This flies in the face of this contradicts
disproves the narrative we've heard from the
right wing that there was this big conspiracy
against Trump and conservatives in the build up
to the 2020 election trying to take him down. If
that was the case, they would not have been doing
so much breaking their back to prevent their
own employees from moderating Trump's content,
from holding him accountable with the rules
they've already had laid out. Number two takeaway.
This is absolutely a part of what led
to January six, what caused January 6th,
the ability for this far right extremism to
fester, for these lies to spread. And so everyone
has different takes on how we address that. And
that's an interesting conversation. But we can
just recognize reality and say a big role in all
of this in the January six attack in the lies and
the speed in which they were able to spread is the
fact that Twitter and other social media platforms
absolutely did not apply their own rules, their
own standards to these individuals the same way
they were to somebody else. And then the third
is, going forward, let's take this as a lesson
and let's figure out what are we going to do
going forward. And so social media platforms,
us just as a country in the public discourse,
need to sort out. It's going to be tough because.
We're also having conversations with individuals
that we're talking about being the problem. Right.
But figuring out how we move forward and not allow
this level of deceit, this level of dishonesty,
and then the reaction to that by the platforms
being to assist not necessarily intentionally,
but assist in that through their fear of backlash
and their lack of enforcing their own rules.
We need to figure out how to handle that
going forward for sure. Make sure that you
are subscribed to The David Pakman Show channel.
What you're watching if you're watching on YouTube
right now and I have a show of my own. When I'm
not hosting the show, I'm hosting the Luke Beesley
Show and you can find that at Luke Beasley
Bazley on YouTube. Hit that subscribe button.